i made less than fifteen hundred dollars
after taxes and and this is so that kind
of gives you the the bottom line is the
bigger the biggest expenses would
probably be the the the cast so the fact
that you have that
who knows who knows it was it was a
shoestring budget like that that's for
sure and they sold advertising and mtv
did amazing on their advertising budgets
for sure and um they
uh
it was the highest ratings that they had
had for any kind of a programming like
that of course they would get higher
ratings for the vmas you know this would
but as far as like
yeah half hour episode series like
we smashed all records so in a half hour
just so that people know in a half hour
you usually deliver 22 minutes of
television
right so 21 22 minutes which means
there's eight minutes of advertising to
sell that's targeted specifically they
were making millions and millions and
millions of dollars and at the end of
the season even though you had a lot of
notoriety you walked away fifteen
hundred dollars right that's amazing for
sure
um but now so because the profit margin
was so crazy and it came out they they
were in mtv was was notorious for reruns
they were rerunning jackass at like 5
p.m like because it was just like oh my
god let's put this out there this is
great and in very short order they
had kids showing up in hospitals all
over the country because they were like
inspired to go and film their own
jackets like
seth yep
and uh
so there was an immediate backlash and
particularly uh leading the charge was
senator joe lieberman you know like oh
we've got this outrage we've got the you
know the shut down this show
and um
they uh
there wasn't actually any lawsuits i'm
aware of it with the exception of uh the
lapd sued because knoxville had this
great bit
that where he dressed up in an orange
jumpsuit and went into a hardware store
with handcuffs on asking for a hacksaw
and they called the cops and the cops
showed up and like when the cops showed
up the
this female cop like got out of her car
but she didn't put it in parks so the
crop guards went slamming into a uh
telephone pole and i think that that
might have been embarrassing for the
police and so they wanted to really
and they settled that lawsuit for i
understand like five thousand people was
mtv protective of you did they would
they handle the liability or did you
ever see the the ramifications
personally or
i was bitten by a shark on the the you
know i filmed that whole first season in
in the space of one week
uh actually five days and i only filmed
personally on three of the five days but
i got my finger bitten by a shark and
i've got like a cool little scar on my
finger um
and i didn't even go to the hospital i
just had the medic bandaged it up and i
had that you had that still had that
wrap from the baby [ __ ] yeah
this was uh prior to that but um
yeah i didn't even go to the hospital
but it was a
few weeks later i got something in the
mail from mtv saying us please forward
us your hospital bills
so we can cover them and i thought wow
like no if i get hurt like they they pay
for it yeah you know this is crazy after
you've already healed from your shark
attack right
and uh
right and um but but in any case
the there there weren't like big
lawsuits over kids getting hurt there
was a general back then there was a real
sense you guys are a bad influence you
guys are are inspiring kids to get hurt
you are this really bad thing and with
the senator joe lieberman and all of the
backlash coming around what what
happened was even though there weren't
lawsuits there were very distinctly
uh there was a lot of uh
you know pressure on mtv and mtv's
standards and practices where these are
the people who are sort of the arbiters
of what's allowed on on tv or not like
the censorship board basically they
started really leaning on us and and not
uh you know not allowing certain stuff
we filmed to be included in the show and
even prior to filming they wouldn't give
us approval to go through with certain
bits and you know they were trying to
water down the show and knoxville
i wouldn't have it he said uh you know
well if you if if you're not going to
let us do what we do the way we do it
then i quit
and for the rest of us sort of
supporting cast the sidekicks were kind
of like
what do you do in knoxville
what do you mean but i think that he had
a plan all along because he very much
wanted to be like a big time movie star
and so he was like
[ __ ] this basic cable nonsense like let
me quit the show while it's on top of
the world and then
make them and give us a movie deal
because once you uh once you make an
r-rated movie you take away that layer
of liability now it's like
only for
you know people in hindsight he's saying
she would i had a plan guys i i i don't
doubt that he had that plan for all all
along i mean they mtv had had big but i
get it you know i get listen i i'm in
network television right now and you you
have to answer to the you have to answer
to the advertisers when you're
advertising supported if you want to
make something
on your own then you don't have to and
they
their money is not coming from you their
money is coming from an advertiser so i
kind of understand right and
to go back to the original question you
know
well the original question here was uh
you know about that do you have a weird
tattoo no
i was asking because i'm still sitting
in between
the copycat kids yeah you know is that
something that we feel bad like in the
beginning there was there was a
certain amount of heat you know with the
copycat kids still to this day you want
to be careful of uh of what's called
like imitatable you know you don't want
to be too too imitatable but um
the reason why i asked what uh time
frame his stunts happened in is because
with the advent of youtube with like all
this like you know digital content
coming from over now everybody's got a
video camera in their pocket on their
cell phone like it's really not about
jackass anymore you know i don't think
that jackass
can even be pointed to as like the
inspiration for this diction
because now it's just click bait you can
get views and stuff like that right i
mean so i just don't think that you know
and back then when people would you know
sort of complain about about what what
uh
you know a bad influence we are we we
were i i would always say hey you know
like it's not tony hawk's fault every
time a kid falls off a skateboard you
know i worked hard to to get to a point
where i call myself a professional and
if some kid's going to see what i do
professionally and then get hurt doing a
half-assed copycat job then
you know yeah it's on them as you always
say
you always say
i don't know like that was the position
i took back then and i would always add
on top of that sort of you know
indignant you know position that i took
i would say also like i'm i'm an
attention [ __ ] i'm not really looking
to share the spotlight so [ __ ] stop
it kids
i love that what a great psa
[Music]
you